ready here we go
all right scum and melanie
everybody put your hands together
for mark bernard and raul coley
black man beyond
oh
hey
hello
hey
hello
hello everybody and welcome to black man
beyond i am mark bernardin
and i'm rahul khali
[Music]
[Applause]
how's everybody doing tonight
[Music]
uh thank you for coming out this is uh
this is always a joy and a pleasure and
the best part of any given week to be
able to come here and [ __ ] talk about
nerd [ __ ] uh kevin as you know is not
here because otherwise
drastic transformation
uh no hockey jerseys no hockey jerseys
apparently jersey's been very good to
you um yeah kevin is still i think today
was the last day on clerk's three um and
so he'll be making his way back
west right that's where we are uh
shortly but for now i get
who's gonna [ __ ] hang out with me
today
[Music]
uh and also this is the first time we've
met we've been just like you know kind
of pen pals for a while
yeah you know trading little [ __ ]
like hey man how are you doing i'm good
what are you working on i'm building
some [ __ ] in my workshop i'm like what
are you doing you know playing smoking
for games like i know okay ladies and
there was that for a couple of years but
now and we finally finally [ __ ] made
it happen yeah yeah we've been trying to
do this for a while yeah because
i've i've been a fan since episode one
of izombie oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't hear that
often i know you're going to say blind
manor or something no one says i zombie
no i was i was i was a die-hard eye
zombier
primarily because i uh i know chris
robertson who wrote the comic book oh
sweet yeah like he's a buddy um and so
when the show was like i got to see what
they did to your book man i can see if
they butch
i mean it's totally not the book but it
still was it was incredibly charming and
a lot of fun and and how you build that
show out of that book i found it really
kind of fascinating and then i was like
hey that dude's funny he's doing like
funny [ __ ] in a way that like nobody
else is kind of doing the funny [ __ ]
that i like
and then i watched every [ __ ] episode
all 71 of them i think there were right
something like that
i i hope that's what i got paid for
[Laughter]
your residuals will tell you that story
um
but so so but here's the thing like
we've never met so this is also like a
little bit of a first date um so i guess
we're gonna do some like
that's why i'm i'm getting drunk yeah
absolutely i know it's like i'm nervous
this man needs more vodka
and i might need some skywalker wine
before this night is over oh
there's blue milk here right they they
do have
i've puked it up because i not that it's
bad because i had a birthday party here
and we had that booth over there we all
it was star wars dress-up and i was
obi-wan kenobi yeah and suckling from
the teat
um but tell me tell me a little bit
about you know
you were you grew up in the uk
what is it like being a brown kid who's
a nerd in the uk
oh
not special not special because i feel
like all brown kids in the uk are nerds
well i mean because i know what it was
like being this brown kid growing up a
nerd in new york which was nobody knew
you were a nerd because you couldn't
tell anybody that [ __ ] um but what is it
like what was it like for you growing up
and and feeling these feelings and
having these urges and and you know kind
of tamping them down and keeping them
under the on the down low but just
knowing you wanted to do some [ __ ]
absolutely coming out of the nerd closet
yeah no for real i mean i
i
i've never hit it it's
i've never seen myself as a nerd i think
i think the like nerd culture is so
broad
um
at this point if my mum knows who vision
and wonder is
is is that nerd culture anymore like
it's it's mainstream right so i've never
really
identified as anything but myself which
is so like obviously i have a huge
passion for
um football
my football team at the exact same time
um at the exact same time that i
you know was collecting episode one
merchandise and you know what i mean so
like i was always kind of a
contradiction
and i was never apologetic for like
just liking everything whether it was
popular or unpopular uh the the whole
kind of
cultural
part of it was more
being an actor that that was more of a
thing i had to
kind of excuse
make excuses for
because it it sounds like a stereotype
but like particularly with south asian
culture
not many
kids go into the arts you know it's it's
there's usually a set path for you it's
business it's medicine it's it's law um
what was supposed to be your path
i don't think i was smart enough
so whatever they had set out for me
wasn't gonna happen because i'm stupid
so i
i um
like my sister became a lawyer but but
like
we did this switcheroo i think i was
going into it i was a huge
fan of the star wars movies i actually
wanted to go into special effects so i
was looking at i wanted to go to do
internships and learn about doing cgi
and then somewhere along the way
i think like 17 18 i flipped and i was
like i want to be in front of the camera
and
dropped out of everything and my parents
were
concerned but not because of any kind of
like you you know you should be a good
indian boy and be a doctor my parents
ain't like that it was more like
you're not going to earn like it's a
skit this is ridiculous and you've never
done it before
and you're throwing everything away to
like go to drama school and you don't
even know if you'll get it luckily
everything went the right way but within
the community i was kind of like a
running joke you know till
well i zombie no but still
about today today now who's got the last
laugh yeah yeah
but um but yeah so it was
so that was more of like a
a thing i i felt kind of embarrassed
where i'd make excuses for when everyone
else was super successful and i had just
got like a mango juice commercial
and i was still living at home
and you know but yeah yeah there is that
switch when like because i wanted to be
i wanted to be a writer for a while i
want to be a filmmaker um which there
were not a ton of you know
african-american filmmakers until spike
lee
you know who actually like sort of made
it big like there were absolutely there
were some like i'm not going to say that
hollywood had none of them but you can
count them on one hand and they never
made the kind of movies that i liked
yeah um
but so hollywood became this weird sort
of denigration they're like hey
hollywood how are you doing which is
like you're never going to go to
hollywood and now you go back home i'm
like hey hollywood's like yeah i know
you want to have lunch like i'm not
having lunch with you you used to call
me hollywood you son of a [ __ ]
so was episode one your uh your sort of
ground zero for yeah
i
um it was the special editions because i
think i was
10 or 11 years old and
no one got me into star wars actually
this is so weird this thing changed my
life doritos
james mine too right
in the uk doritos came with you know
pogs or whatever those discs
right so
i i was like snacking on those cool
ranch as a 10 year olds and i'd end up
with these discs with like horn and
carbonite
and i was like i've never seen these
[ __ ] films
what were these what you know so
i ended up the merch worked i asked for
the vhs box set for my birthday
and
friday i think like we weren't allowed
to watch any vhs's or video games during
the week it was a friday night weekend
treat so friday i got home from school i
put a new hope in
and
mind exploded and
i went straight into empire that night
uh and then it was bedtime
i got up at like 6 a.m
and did jedi saturday morning and then
it was like if there's like a line of
where my life was going at that point it
just went
and yeah and it was thanks to doritos
not lucas
it was doritos but yeah so it was the it
was a special editions i knew nothing at
the time i just accepted the movies what
they were
not knowing that
episode one was like 18 months away 24
months away or whatever so
um
then i found out i was like well you
know they're making stories about how
vader became this way
um so that's how it just went into fever
pitch and so and by that point i was
spending pocket money all the time so
episode one merch was just like
everything did your parents get it like
when they're like what is what is
happening here where's the the
hairdresser and the walking garbage can
they did i mean my dad definitely did my
dad
has been a huge influence for me with
like
uh introducing me to stuff like he he
recorded uh
batman 89 for me on vhs and showed me
that and
uh beetlejuice and he got me into the uh
man with no name trilogy so like my dad
was a huge comedy fan so we were getting
like stand up richard pryor
bill hicks that kind of stuff like fed
to us um
inadvertently i don't think he it was
just out of enjoyment it wasn't like he
had some sort of set plan or some sort
of
binder of what what he wants me and my
sister to watch um
but yeah so
um
he got it my mom didn't my mum
she loves it now like she was a big i
think she binged
it was so cool and i'm very grateful to
filoni and um favre for this but like
i was having text messages with my mum
while she was watching the mandalorian
second season
and
was trying to ask like what the what's a
boba fett and
you know like
how did this happen and and i was like
well you know an empire you see bobbitt
and so
because of that show i got to have those
kind of conversations so i was very
grateful for that because i couldn't
have those 20 years ago right you know
that's awesome yeah um okay so you're
you're baby rahul is a star wars nerd
and a football nerd
who's your team
[Music]
that's liverpool
we have we have a jersey right there
just rapping
but yeah
all right
um
and so and then acting comes in and you
decide this is the thing you want to do
right this is your calling to be in star
wars to be in star wars that was a means
to an end all right um how's it going
great
[Laughter]
no it's
um
really well actually um
yeah the paths have crossed and bumped
and whatever but yeah it's
i got lucky that i ended up falling in
love with my job
more than the reason i got into it but
you know what i mean so like i actually
enjoy what i do more than
wanting to be in star wars so it worked
out in the end
what
describe for me what your and i know
this is sounding like a weird interview
like tell me if you could be a tree what
kind of tree would you be
but uh but what
what was your like your life like the
day before you get the eye zombie call
oh
yeah um
so i was 27
i had just
got conned into believing the sexiest
days pick up the 27 year old
i don't i've never spoken about this um
i
was led to believe by my then team that
i had been cast this is so messed up in
a
prequel to doctor who
okay so the audition went out and i
booked it and we signed contracts oh
[ __ ] and it turns out it's a big load of
[ __ ]
and we were cons
and i had already lost faith in my team
because i was like how did you let that
slip through the cracks that this didn't
happen this person had all my time
they signed me um
and it was fraudulent and
at that point i was at the lowest i felt
i was living at home
i had
at that like a line in a soap opera was
as good as it got
um and i'm rapidly approaching
approaching 30 and it's it looks like
it's it's
it's done
and i remember this dude this guy who
said he had the rights to make this
[ __ ] thing he was bashing this guy on
the phone to me he was like cause come
on man if [ __ ] if rob thomas
can make a kickstarter movie for
veronica mars if that crap can get
funded then why can't a doctor who thing
and i was like i don't know what any of
those references are
a month later after a terrible audition
for 24 the london one
i called my team and was like i'm
quitting
i'm done and i remember this like clear
as day and
they were like well okay we'll sit on it
maybe you're just angry give the weekend
or whatever to think about it in the
meantime we have a audition for you for
a pilot called i zombie
and i was like that sounds terrible um
[Laughter]
and then i was so angry i knuckled down
and i kind of took it at my aggression
out on that audition a little bit and
frustrations and i went in on a monday
and by friday they cast me as ravi and
that was it and then
i flew off
and then i always thought as a like a
little lesson that dude was talking so
much [ __ ] on rob thomas to this out of
work actor
and a few weeks later rob's my boss and
i could go that dude was talking [ __ ]
about you
never talk nonsense about other people
how quickly it can come back on you yeah
um but yeah and and
it changed my life it was overnight
just changed everything for me yeah i
mean i'm convinced that for every person
who's in the creative arts there is the
moment for which they would never do it
again
where it's like it's because it's
[ __ ] hard yeah like it's i remember
talking to somebody over the weekend you
know some some young writer who's like
yeah you know like well i'm doing this
i'm doing that i want to break in but i
think it'll happen i was like bro i
don't mean to harsh your vibe
but it probably won't
because there are more people playing
professional baseball than there are who
write for a living
in hollywood like those are the numbers
and so you have to be wide-eyed about
those and you have to realize that it's
the longest of [ __ ] long shots and if
you can make some peace with that then
by all means go for it but you can't
expect it to work you have to the odds
are that it won't yeah and you have to
make some peace with that and so for
every person who finally made it
there was a moment for which they were
just about to give up yeah until one
person one
opportunity one moment in time led them
to just do the one more thing that they
probably might not have done otherwise
um for yours was anger which is awesome
it's always anger
i tell everyone i'm jedi i'm sith i'm
sick i know i'm sith i don't know why i
pretend i'm on blue lightsaber i mean
but they have the most fun they do to be
fair yeah i mean being a jedi sounds
boring
it does
like the height of being a jedi is i got
this nice swampland uh property i'm
gonna build a little hut and no
relationships no no attachments yeah sit
here in the [ __ ] swamp and just wank
until i'm dead
which you're kind of selling it
[Music]
uh would you like to buy my
swap
um
so izombie goes for five years yeah five
years yeah five seasons um what was your
first
yeah
what was your first comic con like
oh my god first comic con uh so we were
we just did the pilot
then we were picked up and we went to
comic-con
and it was it was it was an interesting
one it was
i was obviously the show hadn't come out
yet we were still being
kind of
shown around
no one knew what we were putting out
there no one saw the pilot it's not like
we didn't debut it at the
panel
so we were walking around selling
something
with this log line about sheets the
brains and gets the victims of the
brains and it's called izombie and every
journalist made the same iphone joke and
we were like no it's not an app it's
this
so in terms of selling it it was awkward
and quite kind of frustrating for us
because it was like we wished people had
at least seen the pilot or at least a
trailer not even a trailer so um
but the experience of like
um meeting certain people i never
thought i'd meet and um
i had broken my my hand uh
i think
a month prior to comic con
i was watching a liverpool game and i i
punched the door and i broke my hand
i mean or forced choking a guy yeah oh
no that's better i was force-choking a
jedi yeah and um it's tuesday and flash
forward to comic con
mike tyson was
doing press for his animated show
and i'm standing with mike and mike's
telling me why i broke it and he was
like
you plan thing wrong you need to put i
shouldn't
i don't want to get beat enough but mike
was giving me boxing advice
and i was like this is [ __ ] weird
what's going on and then
this is not going to be a complete name
droppy thing but that's all good um jim
and jim lee was there
and i got introduced to jim lee and
we ended up grabbing some food
afterwards as a group and jim and i were
drawing on napkins and he was improved
giving me techniques
and it was just like it's just the most
surreal dream it was like i got boxing
advice from mike tyson i'm getting
drawing advice from jim lee
um
ign and all the you know we're meeting
all the the people that i would watch
you know um
yeah it was it was
a whirlwind and then the second year was
a lot better because now the show was
out and that's people who what you know
wanted more information where's the show
going to go what's going to happen and
um yeah but it was it got
it became incredible yeah it levels up a
bit yeah were you a kind of person who
wanted to be famous or is it i want to
act and i'll take the fame as a
byproduct
see this is so fame i think anyone who
who
wants fame is it's kind of looked upon
as
especially in the acting world that's
kind of a uh
what's the word i'm looking for it's
it's kind of frowned upon right and it's
anathema
if yeah that sounds right
um i'll google that later
i don't think i wanted fame
i
what i want or what i wanted was to be
the best i could be
and
for south asian representation
we don't have a harrison ford yet right
um we don't have an idris or
benicio del toro dev's there deb's
getting there you know with green knight
and stuff but and riz ahmed but it's
still few and far between yeah like
naveen andrews was the guy like first
absolutely naveen andrews yeah yeah that
was and that was and that was so
important to see because it was like ah
that's one
and that's the best you could hope for
was you know um that kind of level and
this is such a silly thing to admit but
like i'd look at someone like idris i i
felt more closeness to idris than i did
other south asian actors idris is a
london boy
who didn't get
cast very often in in the uk and he went
to america and he booked the wire and
and became a sensation there and built
on that then went back to the uk and he
transcended
idris is idris his idris
he transcends
race nationality everything he's just
idris he's he and and
i wanted that for
south asians i wanted that for for the
little corner i represent
um so with that comes a level of fame
and
box office numbers and all that stuff so
to say do i want to be famous
yes it fits in with what i want and what
i want to be able to
show other young people from the same
part of the world i'm from yeah you can
do it
and we can point to that and say well
he's the lead and
he got the money back so i can be
so yeah right it's it's it's less
fame for fame's sake and more fame as a
tool for power yeah fame is a lever to
move games that's very stiff
but you need that yeah you know it's
it's
when you look at others who've carved
that way
when will smith
would
his name sells the movie
you know men in black you get a big
budget film like that and it kills
um
it's evidence it's evidence that you go
no no it doesn't always have to be the
same way
people are willing to willing to to part
with their money and see this person in
those roles
um and i like i said i think dev and
rizz are
on their way to that um and that's the
path that i'd like to carve out at some
point but i've got a lot of gundams to
build man
[Laughter]
yeah like that's right every time i'm
like i'm just flipping [ __ ] instagram
stories what do i see and i see like
i see this desk that is somehow both
pristine and a chaos area yeah and then
like a piece of a thing and like just
i'm doing it
[Applause]
done next yeah where did that come from
have you been a model builder a kit
builder your whole life or
start it started with star wars like i'd
uh i think someone bought me might have
been my dad or my gran for like
christmas one of the like old-school
rebel model kits it was a i think it was
darth vader's tie fighter so i was
if it had the star wars brown on it i
got it or i was given it um
and in those days what i did was i dip
the brush straight into a
like a tin
and just slather it because i was a kid
i don't know i was doing and i just do
that i was like yeah the tie fight is
silver i reckon
and you just because there's no internet
and then um
i think what so what happened was the
the auditions and the the lack of work
when i was in london was
it was kind of killing me i was very
busy i was auditioning a lot which was
encouraging but i wasn't working so
i needed to be available
and it would get hectic and then there'd
be long periods where it would just go
dead
and i remember
i don't know
seeing one of the star wars kits i was
like i used to do this let me try it
this way but let me try it with youtube
and that's where like as before as i was
dipping the brush back in the tin to do
the the old school method someone's like
you know no you need to do this you need
to prime it airbrush and
so that became kind of this
outlet for creativity
that didn't require another person it
didn't require too much money there was
always workarounds
and it kept me engaged
while i wasn't
working on something and also it kept my
moods in check like i found that i i i'm
not very good at meditating or relaxing
and then
that's one of the only hobbies where
i'll start and six hours went i didn't
eat i haven't gone out for a cigarette
i've just sat there and realized it's
it's you know what i mean it's got that
state there that meditative state
um
so now
when i'm not filming i do that i just
smash out as many kits as i can before
i'm sent away to go and do something
else
uh speaking of things you get sent away
to do i couldn't help but notice you
have a television program oh yeah coming
on to the netflix's
[Applause]
just next month yeah called uh midnight
mass yeah
um what what is it like working in the
sort of flanigan zone oh
um
yeah he's a genius um i caught i i've
called him a surgeon before and
i think one of the
most important things a director uh
a taller director can have his is good
communication skills and funnily enough
it's not that common
the amount of times you stand with the
director who has the best intention
can't communicate with you doesn't know
how to ask you to do with the thing that
you want
um
mike from is like
a neurosurgeon he can come in be concise
tell you one thing change your entire
performance he's just he's so
hands on and
you get spoiled it's why like certain
people work with the same director again
and again and again when you get that
kind of um
support and
uh
yeah he so
it was kind of love at first sight for
me with him i don't think he feels the
same way but
it's like
when i when i first started working with
him on blind manor um
he kind of
was sizing me up and asking me questions
that had nothing to do with my character
owen
uh
and this went on for a month and then
i'd get a phone call and he'd take away
text me and be like
um
how old do you think you can play
i don't know 40s okay and then disappear
again for another week
what was this
and then at some point i was like yo
mike stop flirting
let's have a meet and what is this thing
that you keep like sizing me up for and
it was midnight mass
and he pitched it to me and
i was still on bly and um
within 15 minutes of him telling me the
story i was like i mean
and he was like you need to talk to a
team and lawyers first before i was like
i don't care do not give this role to
anyone else i don't care if dev patel's
available it's my role
and then yeah and then we made it happen
and that was midnight mass and i'm very
appreciative it's
it's um
it's the best show i've ever been in
yeah yeah yeah what happens in the last
episode
[Laughter]
it ends oh
yeah
did not see that coming credits wow um
what is a i i've i've been on sets
before and and i'm always curious
because sets can be the most boring
places in the world yeah um but also the
the tenor and the tone of the set is
somehow always a little contrary to the
content you're making
so what is a mike flanagan horror show
set like
so i don't know because blind manor
wasn't
it wasn't horror horror you know it was
a gothic horror it was a romance
um
i
every now and again we'd be like most of
my scenes were very fun
light-hearted
um
and then i'd be doing a scene in an hour
later i'd realized that there was a
little boy under the table in a doll's
mask
no one told me so that he'd be in the
frame just down there and like oh what's
up mate all right
it's it's i mean mike has said before
the
horror sets are usually the funniest
they're ridiculous
you know you're
i i know from the the lady of the lake
for instance you know the the the actors
in those masks they're kind of funny
without the cgi and
between takes you see them trying to put
like a straw in there with a you know
with their coat it's just it's
ridiculous and and fun um
and then on top of that it's hard to
gauge
like
i think
horror films are really made in post
you know our sets were super bright and
colorful
and you'd go this ain't gonna this ain't
creepy what are we building then you
watch it you realize once it's been
colored
and there's a score and you receive the
framing you're like oh this is
unsettling but for the most part it was
just
cooking sausages
with a moustache
and i used to fart a lot because we had
kids on set and i that was my way of
making them laugh was just a fart
although once i did it
and
um i thought it was because my farts are
usually scentless oh really they don't
smell no yeah because i'm not healthy i
feel like healthy people make horrible
smelling farts
all that protein and broccoli don't
smell good mine's just mcdonald's
so
i did
i thought i'd do a little silent one
because i needed to right before scene
and then one of the kids started heaving
and then the other kids smiled they
started heaving and i couldn't own up to
it
so we had to leave set
and fan it and i just don't know they
can watch this
it was me i did it
[Music]
i uh
i i don't know how to follow that
question
[Applause]
i have a good idea i'ma read an ad
manscaped
manscaped
would you like to watch me read a map
that does work yeah i mean i was gonna
do a whole [ __ ] segue about how
beautiful your facial hair is
and then i don't use the trimmer that i
use on my balls for my face so that
would have been a hard way for you to
get to manscape i mean it's it's a it's
a detour but you know what i do use tell
me manscape manskins i do actually yeah
do you
excellent
i'm gonna read this copy
of the audience
oh what is it hello
this is skywalker rosie
we are we
brew no wine before it's time skywalker
it's amazing that was my anakin ah very
nice
[Applause]
i've got sand in my teeth
it tastes like rosie all right so like i
i could do the vampy we'll have a good
time with this but i feel like
you'll see the spirit of it if i just
read it [ __ ] cold
attention listeners across the galaxy
this mind you manscape wrote this
uh attention listeners across the galaxy
all the way from australia to houston
do you have a pube problem
yes
uh insert space music here if so our
friends at manscape have cleared you for
takeoff with their fourth generation and
brand new lawnmower 4.0
kick your pubes to the next planet
with the performance package 4.0
the orbits in your pants will feel like
you're in zero gravity when you use the
best tools for the job for the leaders
in male grooming
join the two million men worldwide who
trust manscaped
and get your rocket ready for liftoff
by going to manscape.com
fat man for 20 off plus free shipping
also they're not just rockets like pod
racers
and
for sure unmanned ships and speeder
bikes and maglev trains yeah yeah it
doesn't have to just be big rockets that
needs to no no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
totally
[Applause]
ready for an out of world experience
fellas
sold
yes
uh i hope you all are enjoying the very
last manscaped ad read because they're
not gonna ask me to do this anymore
uh
look no further than the performance
package 4.0 from manscape that has just
taken off not only in the usa but canada
uk
across europe australia south africa and
singapore
um blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah more liftoff 4.0 lawn mower
trimmer
advanced skin safe technology a new
multi-function on off switch that can
engage a travel lock because you don't
want that thing [ __ ] just going ramp
in your suitcase no
no just buzzing pubes especially if you
look like me you don't want your
suitcase to do anything it shouldn't do
thought of that yes thank you manscaped
making buzzing things in your luggage
safe for brown men ever
[Applause]
the performance package 4.0 also
includes the weed whacker
it's like having a little astronaut to
chop your worst weeds up top in your
nose and ear oh
i was going somewhere else with a weed
whacker
that's for your nose yeah for your nose
gotcha yeah yeah no totally safe
uh
that's cocaine though right your nose
weed is cocaine
uh
manscape does not sell cocaine
disclaimer no i felt like it was satan
no i needed to say that not anymore
um
abort hairy balls
and buzz lightyear that woody
with manscaped this is serious i don't
know why everyone's left this is serious
stuff yeah no
so get 20 off plus free shipping by
going to manscape.com
fat man
that's 20 off plus free shipping by
going to
manscape.com fat man f a t m a n
for a clean trinity and beyond
your spaceballs will thank you
thanks you guys i feel i feel uh
i feel dirty
in a weirdly antiseptic way then use one
all right you feel super clean
afterwards yeah oh yeah really changed
my life like high stepping but i've only
got a 3.0
i didn't know about the four-pointer you
had a [ __ ] stuff you know what i mean
i feel like i should get one now
it'll change your life
um
now is the part of the show
where uh we would talk about the things
that we may or may not have seen in the
world uh what are you watching these
days man
thanks to uh jacob sitting over there uh
i'm watching mobile suit gundam zeta
how how is the mobile suit it's great
so oh i'm watching i've watched that oh
yeah i'm on it
um
it's the the thing i love about the
original
gundam shows from the 70s and 80s yeah
is
how often someone gets slapped
it's so [ __ ] it's every five seconds
someone is just getting backhanded in
the mouth and then told to be more of
this or that it's um this seems like a
weird military yeah that's the only
corporal punishment is slapping people
yeah and i think that's like we could
bring that back that's fine i don't like
that's better than a like prison
sentence or something just a good
backhand in your mouth
i'm getting flashbacks and then i hope
so like fifth grade
um that also seems like awfully dramatic
yes because the backhand is not like an
are you still [ __ ] like
that's a wind-up oh and there's like
speed lines and [ __ ] to get to the other
face and then a big sound effect that
may or may not appear as type on screen
of what get got
and then oh
when you're when you're backhanded you
yeah it has to be that big whereas i
think the front one is more oh
because also you're surprised that you
didn't see it coming yeah because the
backhand is like a [ __ ] wind up you
got to do all of that in motion to get
there like a quick pat that's like
[ __ ] cats do that [ __ ]
when did we stop slapping people with
gloves
i don't feel like we do that enough
like you know
yeah well we don't wear gloves as much
anymore i think they went out with capes
i feel like if you if you were like a
cloak and a cane dude you also had
gloves with witches and the white gloves
yeah you just tuck into your [ __ ]
waistcoat like right under your little
chain that had your monocle on it he's
like [ __ ] yeah i got my slapping gloves
[ __ ]
we're not you can do it with masks now
yeah oh well you need to wait the masks
though you gotta like you gotta fill the
mask with like a roll of coins oh that's
that's some prison [ __ ]
well you need yeah well yeah or like a
tiny bag of oranges like a little bit of
tangerines that's in your mouth a
clementine yeah
um
i i have never seen any mobile suit
gundam uh any any uh whatever suffix you
had at the end of that um
zeta oh i've missed i've i haven't seen
the officers have you seen you haven't
seen doubles ate uh
thunderbolt and there's so many of them
i uh i'm never going to no
and that's fair it's you know what it is
it's it's just because
when i it's it's the researcher in me
uh i wanted to build a gundam just
because of i was interested with the
design of it right uh and what happens
is that i can't just do it and then not
know anything about it uh
so then i go into the deep dive
so okay let me watch this documentary
about it let me understand the culture
behind it let me understand who it is
i'm building and what these things are
and then it led me to watching the show
and that's how it just bled into it's
just
it always happens for me i get super
fixated on a particular thing
and i'll drop it just as quick as i
picked it up but i'm very intense for a
few months on one topic and that's
you know
like when i was doing a zombie
for
about a month or i lived and breathed
autopsies
like i was looking at the worst [ __ ] you
could find on the internet i was
watching real autopsies i was watching
footage of people exhuming coffins
oh yeah yeah then i was interviewing
pathologists then i went to a morgue and
looked at real like murder victims in
the fridges and
and then and then once we were done and
when you think about izombie because
you've seen it yeah there's a waste of
time of doing that in it it's a lot i
mostly just held rats and like [ __ ]
wore stupid outfits yes somebody was
spending a lot of time very artfully
photographing brain food yeah to make it
look like delicious food yeah um but no
you went deep and i think
the writers would have appreciated the
level of detail that they never played
into it they didn't care but what it did
breed what i was lucky enough to see was
like
you just need a small thing and and it
was how comfortable
um the medical examiner was in their
space in their workspace the humor the
darks the dark humor that they had that
we we took straight away and
um yeah and
so i i have that same kind of thing
towards gundam it's just because i
started building one i need to watch the
shows i need to watch everything i need
to i need to see it all i listen to the
soundtrack in the car it's a mess
ah
wow yeah
i mean good for you
because it sounds like it's working out
so far
but in about a month people still be
tweeting me about it i'm like stop
tweeting me about gundams i don't give a
[ __ ] because that's how quick i'll just
like switch off [ __ ] off
uh have you watched any of uh what if
no
oh the marvel yes what if nah no no
uh have you guys seen the what-ifs
[Applause]
how how do we feel about the what-if as
sure
because the thing about it is each one
is a very specific siloed uh experience
right like every episode is a standalone
which sort of leads one to believe that
you don't have to feel the same way
about all of them okay um
i i who
who loved uh captain carter
who loved uh t'challa star-lord
and who loved agatha christie's uh were
killing all the avengers
i i feel like that that is about where i
am with it as well
um for all kinds of reasons yeah but
even if you even if you take away
the uh
the the just emotional detonation you
get in your soul to hear chadwick
boseman do t'challa for the livestream
that was his last record that's his last
role
was like and it's so much fun yeah and
he's so light on his feet and he's
having the best time
and so that automatically becomes like
weepy and [ __ ] when you're just watching
it's like
a good time
but it's also a really fun episode yeah
it's and the the what-if conceit of it
is i think the most fully realized
captain carter is also a ton of fun and
it's gorgeous and is that voiced by um
haley like yeah they spent all the money
and got almost everybody back you know
it's there's a couple of like uh well
they didn't get robert downey jr back
because who are we kidding and like
that's not really chris evans and but
everybody else is like oh [ __ ] they're
sebastian stan and there's samuel
jackson oh there's jeremy renner and
there's
um
that one felt a little like it was too
close to the first avengers storyline
just swapping out peggy for for steve
yeah and so it started to get a bit
predictable like you could see
the the boxes they were gonna check but
it's still fun have they done a uh what
if a fantastic four movie was good
uh i think that's still in process
i think they're still working on that
yeah uh i have uh i've seen
the internet
embrace the idea oh of um of you john
krasinski
no
no i mean that was a couple years ago
everybody's like he's fine
he's married emily blunt he's good but
i've seen quite a bit
of rahul
as reed richards
[Applause]
thanks
i'm being a cynic here
it's because i sort of look like brown
gym
like i'm not i was getting i was getting
brown jim brown gym
on i zombie trailers
so i've always had this like i i can
kind of vaguely see it when i have a
beer than that but like i've always and
i and so what i thought was we want john
krasinski we want john kozinski and then
it was like or
the brown version of john krasinski so i
felt like i'm not getting it because i'm
right for reed richards i'm getting it
because i'm like a
tan
john krasinski if you don't get john
krasinski
but that's me being a cynic
true but also and i'm getting gray
you you're going great yeah but also
however you get it
get it
sure like you can be there 2 a.m but
you've just seen my social media disney
aren't hiring me in a [ __ ] heartbeat
um we'll have to clean that up first
before feige calls but yeah i
it's it's flattering of course it is
like the fan cast and stuff is super
flattering yeah
it reached like
a ridiculous fever pitch with um
rebels with ezra bridger
which i don't have so
but but um
but i've stopped encouraging it because
like with anything in the internet
they always find a way to make it go bad
you know what i mean so like
yeah i was watching rebels one morning
and i knew that they there was this i
had a comic book because someone tweeted
like
disney are looking for a south asian
representation to play ezra bridger and
that was in the back of my head for a
while and then i was going to the gym
while shooting midnight mass and i went
oh just about to go get into low fall
orphan shape something like that
and
and then i i was working out
finished got on my phone my manager had
called me
there were articles i had texts from
people congratulations
and i was like oh no
and i look and i had made him trend and
i was like i didn't know anyone gave a
[ __ ] this was stupid i was just doing a
thing so people were like so i started
having fun with it
so i i i did a video apology immediately
saying that's not true i am not in the
mandalorian i'm not ezra bridger but i
had the music playing in the car
because i'm a troll and i thought you
you lot of [ __ ] grown-ups like i'm
trolling when would disney let an actor
do that like you just common sense
they'd never let you do that
and then boss logic got involved and he
does the art and stuff
and then everyone gets over it and go ah
he was playing that was fun it was fun
to see support for a character and
rebels fans
and then it gets nasty and then it's
like you'll never be ezra bridger you
[ __ ] uh not my ezra you prick
all right i'm not doing this no more so
even like so i get this the dopest like
reeds richard's art
and people want me as the doctor and
doctor who and they want like i'm always
getting thrown in this stuff and i and
honestly for a kid who used to like role
players bruce wayne and like that that
was that was a kid i was there was no
ceilings right i was just i wanted to be
these guys
and then to see others agree with you
even if it's a small amount that's one
of the most wonderful feelings
particularly being a person of color is
when people are like no you are mr
fantastic to us
you don't need to be white
um so every time i see that and i see
that engagement and i hear the cheers
and that kind of thing it really really
touches me and it means a lot to me
i can't publicly support it anymore
because it just gets nasty and it turns
into like i'm panhandling or i'm
i'm begging for this or i'm out of work
i'm unemployed i'm there like it just
gets so nasty but um
yeah you know if they want me to do it
fine i'll do it
i'll trust my arm if i go for it
everyone will work something out or
whatever
um all of which is to say
you should watch what if i will because
it's it's
it's gorgeous i didn't realize that um
that chadwick had voiced it that alone
is yeah i want to boot that up for sure
and and and the the ways they tweak the
guardians and that entire world is super
fun and super fast and they got all the
[ __ ] voices back yeah like benicio
del toro comes back to play the
collector because
what else is he doing and it sounds like
the kind of thing he'd find just [ __ ]
fun like that tickles me
i'll do it i know what he's doing
because i auditioned for it oh yeah
so he's doing something yeah no i don't
know
i don't know if he's working i literally
just did an audition for one of the
projects
uh
all right that is the legit kind of all
i'm watching because i'm also in a are
you playing anything i'm
playing
the assassin's creed uh valhalla
oh
um
the siege of paris dlc which they just
dropped and you know it is less because
the story is like it's it's perfectly
well written i really dig it but i just
want to [ __ ] murk people in the
streets you know like i just want to be
on a rooftop and i'm going to kill that
dude what do you do nothing
you know it's it's it is my getting my
sort of nwa fantasies out but in period
yeah it's like cosplay nwa was like i
didn't have to use my sieve today yeah
um but i did because i'd [ __ ] just
kill people sweet it's kind of fun um
what else am i playing i was playing the
the beta for back for blood the
did you ever play left 4 dead
yes but very like not not i didn't get
super into it but yeah i played it yeah
like back in the day like there were
there were a bunch of it ended up being
this weird screenwriter slash comic book
writers would all go on left for dead
and then like break story while killing
zombies you know she'd be like oh she's
[ __ ] left your dad's like oh yeah
there's fraction and there's bendis and
what are we talking about today i'm
talking about [ __ ] no way so it
became like an online forum like a
little bit yeah like if you knew the
names and you knew the times that they
were going on you can just stumble in
and [ __ ] hang out with those dudes
and so i did that a lot and also killing
zombies cooperatively is a ton of fun
yeah and so uh i don't know if you guys
have done that but like it's really fun
when you and your buddies because it's a
team building exercise really um but
back for blood is the sort of next-gen
console that was on the like the
original xbox the 360. um and so this is
the the updated version and it's still
super fun but it's a beta so there's
like a little bit to play yeah um but it
still it remains cool to kill zombies i
don't know if you know that i wouldn't
know about that no i cure him i don't
kill him oh
i would be against you in our world you
know vehemently against you i'm sorry
you know there there there was going to
have to be the malcolm x and uh and
martin luther king and the fallout yeah
like we would be just diametrically
opposed
on how we should treat zombies yeah yeah
we know there shouldn't be lots of them
it's not great but you would save them
and convert them and i would kill them
so you're malcolm x yes yeah yes i'm the
by any means necessary dude and i'm dr
king yeah
now
i don't want anyone to do photoshop
please can you not i don't actually want
to play dr king i gotta be explicit
about stuff like that i know i i
realized as we started going down into
this cul-de-sac it was a bad idea he's
like we should like back out here
quickly but i didn't i kept going
i'm glad you were uh the saner mind
prevailed yeah i've got you um should we
do some news
sure let's talk about some news now is
the part of the show
where uh where i as a former newsman
uh put back on my press cap which i keep
uh my my uh my auschwitz chapeau i i
pull out of the closet and and put it
back on and then i hunt for news okay
which is really just me copying pasting
from like deadline
lighter and [ __ ] i'm not breaking news i
don't care that much well i don't i
haven't looked at the internet today so
this breaking to me
it's nothing is relative to who knows it
very much so um were you a fan of the
rocketeer
i was in it
did you know that you didn't know that i
didn't know you were in the racketeer
so there's a disney junior rocketeer
animation that start came out a year ago
[ __ ] you're born in 85.
all right so technically disney did work
with me despite my tweets um i play
one of the characters dads in that
animated show which won emmy's excellent
which i didn't get invited to
uh i bet she was like the creative arts
i mean she knows that there was fun
prime time
oh those are the words i don't even know
what that is
but i brag about it but i don't know
what it is it's all good yeah um so then
you've seen the rocketeer
yes a long time ago yeah um there have
been lots of rumblings and attempts to
sort of rejuvenate the ip
and i think that that
for people like me who grew up with the
original rocketeer um
it's an amazing movie if you've never
seen it it's it is it is the best
superhero movie that nobody gets credit
for being a superhero movie it's so
lovely and it's full of so much heart
it's it's raiders plus [ __ ] jet packs
yeah like who doesn't love that um
disney plus has now greenlit a new
rocketeer called return of the rocketeer
which is being produced and potentially
starring david yellow
dr king dr [ __ ] king came back all
comes around look how we did that
just like we do this every week
um
yes and and i think the the refit of it
is it's still the same jet pack that
that cliff c court gets yeah but now
falls into the hands of an old tuskegee
airman
um
who gets his hands on it and a lot of it
is about and i think it's an
intergenerational story so it's him as
his kid
but the idea of of repositioning this
beautiful old ip that's a period story
but then being honest with the period
that you're in and telling that version
of it um i can't [ __ ] wait i can't
[ __ ] wait that's a great show yeah
that sounds awesome i'm all for it
um does anybody want more rocketeer
yeah oh there's more
uh
please uh how about more jungle cruise
because we're getting more jungle cruise
did you know that i i feel like we were
gonna yeah it did well it did well it
made a hundred million dollars at the
box office which given the box service
we're currently in is like a billionaire
yeah absolutely it's titanic it's
titanic for sure um and so and i have
the feeling that if the rock wanted to
make another one they weren't going to
say no because i don't feel like he's a
dude you say no to a lot
um because i've seen his cheat meals and
i've seen his workout plans and is it
those those pancakes yeah where's just
mounds of a company looks like he robbed
an ihop
[Music]
it's ridiculous you don't need to be
that you i i went to a gym once once
and
um he and he
and he was there what yeah so i i was
this is back in london years ago
the gym i went to is called bulldogs jim
oh tough and bulldog owned it and
bulldog at the time was the guinness
world record holder for squats
and that gym was like you needed a
tetanus shot before you went in like
everything was rusty every now and again
you'd hear someone scream because a
cable snapped
and like they were flying
we'd like we would do rope pull downs
the the thing was fraying
and we walk in like one afternoon
and the rock is just there
this is like a behind a supermarket this
is a very like low-key sort of place and
the rock is in there doing squats with
bulldogs this is for fast and furious
that was in london oh it was like seven
or something i don't know like six
yeah yeah i'll take your word for it
i've never seen him maybe i mean seven
is the one i think where he and vin
diesel didn't talk to each other and
like weren't on screen at the same time
oh
yeah i want one of those yeah i know i
want one of those feeds i'm going to
like make one happen it's a good few
yeah absolutely i want one where they go
rahul shot this separately because he
didn't want to talk to rose
i just think it's something sweet that i
shouldn't have beef with um but yeah the
rock was in there and
on paper we're the same height
but we're not
so that makes sense when someone's so
big and famous
they were bigger than you
and they were still but they're the same
height as you you he just didn't make
sense as proportions i was like i was
looking up
but we're the same height
and it's like thighs they didn't make
sense they were just yeah they're like
three of mine um
i'd still say no to him yeah well all
right to work out with him i would
definitely
shove up your ass i'm not scared i'm
working out with you mate [ __ ] skip
leg day
i i met him once
i was uh it was the first time that i
had been in in la as like a normal
person who was a kid but i was a grown
ass man um and i was visiting a friend
who was living in calabasas and uh and
so i flew out went to his house and it's
like yeah yeah i gotta i gotta hit the
supermarket i go to ralph's which i
didn't know what i was coming from new
york it's [ __ ] ralph's oh you're from
new york i am which bar i was born in
the bronx yeah um grew up on the south
shore of long island and then moved to
jersey and then from jersey out to l.a
and then outside gotcha yeah so i'm in
i'm in ralph's with my friend adam and
we're walking down these [ __ ] things
by and i don't remember what the hell we
were buying it's not nothing good we're
two fat dudes um so it's not like we're
vegetables
um
and so we're walking down the frozen
aisle and on the other end of the frozen
isle is the rock
and look with this with a [ __ ]
carriage like he's pushing a cart he's
shopping yeah and like you can see the
like the the windows fogging up as he
would pass by in the frozen aisle like
he's just radiating heat
and uh
and at the time adam and i had written
this comic book called monster attack
network um
and disney had optioned it to make it a
movie and their plan was the rock was
going to be the star oh so we were like
we should go introduce ourselves to the
rock because he's going to be in our
movie and that's not weird at all
two dudes rolling up on a dude
in the frozen you're gonna be in our
movie
so adam is all for it i'm kind of
holding back i'm like dude this this
feels weird like i don't want to ask
this girl to dance
and so we then just followed him around
the store that's not weird yeah that's
what you do you know like like i'm
trying to build up my courage you know
[ __ ] let's go in he's like he's like
a dude doing double dutch like he's just
ready to [ __ ] dive in and i'm like i
don't know about this man i'm a girl
tripped up he's like no [ __ ] go
and so we're following him around the
store and we finally get to like the
checkout aisle and and and he's like
pulling in and we're coming around and
then he swivels on us
and he's like can i help you he knew you
were stalking him and uh
he's like what what do you want
this is exactly what you want to happen
for someone to be in your mind
going exactly the right way for sure
so uh i said well
we just wanted to see
what the rock was cooking
you you are very successful and
wonderfully talented
and i think that you [ __ ] up so bad
then he may still not want to work with
him
he just
gave us the people's eyebrow i it just
went back to his life
of you know eating turkeys by the
fistful and
but yeah that's that is my one that is
my rock story
it's amazing it's not bad so yeah
they're making another jungle cruise
yeah
because
that's what this news story you've got
to pay for all that protein
and pancakes that shit's not free
no although you'd think he'd have like
ihop endorsements by now like denny's is
like the nfl has a tire endorsement we
are the official tires of the nfl like
why doesn't he have weird official
pancakes for the rock sure because i
feel like he promotes that stuff but
isn't that protein pancakes they're
different uh yeah but i don't want
anyone to believe that you can go ihop
eat 16 of those and get shredded i think
they're special pancakes
but dennis was smart oh yeah sure
protein pancake yeah yeah i mean he
sells booze like he's not sounding like
crazy healthy night did you did you ever
go to denny's when um they had the solo
promotion no
they had a solo themed menu
yeah and um i went with you guys
bruce what is bruce there what was the
name of the the
what did they change the grand slam to
for solo
can you remember
it was a millennium falcon something
yeah it was but like everything was
themed of course it was a good summer i
uh
the only time i did that was when they i
think denny's did a a hobbit promotion
and so it was like eat like a home yes
second breakfast yeah lots of like
hobbiton pancakes and like dancing pony
waffles or whatever the [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] with just like weird
icing on it
like oh this icing is shorter it's a
short stack because they're hobbits
[ __ ] so yeah uh jungle cruise 2 is
happening we all care have you seen
jungle cruise one i did see jungle
cruise one is it good it's fine
i mean like at home in my house for 30
bucks
um it's a little overpriced but it's
also a movie i was not gonna go out and
see like i was gonna like
dance to the theater for jungle cruise
yeah but uh i had a good time with it
silly but fun good fun for the farmer
it's like romancing with stone oh and i
haven't loved that as a kid yeah so it's
got some of that like spencer tracy like
hepburn and tracy like banter stuff if
the special effects are pretty cool but
it's an adventure and we're solving
clues and all of that [ __ ] it's fun well
when a movie is named after a disney
write i'm not expecting
you know saving private ryan although i
would ride that ride that would be right
yeah the other way around my
expectations are high yeah sure i'm
gonna storm this [ __ ] here that's why
pirates of cabaret like came out of left
field because i think everyone thought
that was dead in the water
and it was incredible the first one that
movie is great yeah yeah um
especially because the energy of that
movie is
watching
johnny depp steal a movie out from the
dude who thought he was the lead
like orlando bloom is convinced that
that's his movie and i think he probably
still is
and
and just watching the the the grand
larceny of a dude just like stealing
every scene he's sure to the point where
he's like well where's that guy but i i
love it when
that every now and again you there's a
movie where you know that actor is
they know they're killing it everyone
around them knows they're killing it
like
everyone and i truly believe this about
actors non-actors we all have that one
performance in us
that kills
that is just
you know like
heath's joker when you watch it it's
goosebumps and you know that the crew
and everyone around them you know when
someone is doing stuff like that it's
just like
it's incredible and i felt that way
watching jungle cruise
no i didn't i hadn't seen it i was just
bringing it back on topic because i was
i was losing everyone because i was
[ __ ] over yeah no but like to your
point like watching usual suspects like
i like that movie a lot beneath you
yeah is like next level in a completely
different movie and you can tell the
movie's starting to bend around him like
we don't know what to do with this this
energy we don't i flip you i flipped it
for real
what is he yeah huh it's malkovich in
the in that [ __ ] poker movie yeah he
was like paid the admi and his money do
you know i was uh rounders watched um
there will be blood recently
and
i saw it in the cinema i'm a big donald
daley lewis fan and when i watched that
movie i couldn't help
i could only watch him
no one else existed that movie and i
watched it again and
i think it was alana that that pointed
out paul dano in that
oh he's great oh my god he's so good
like
it's a shame that you're next to daniel
day-lewis because i couldn't see you bro
because daniel's is like
the whole way i'm just everything daniel
does i'm just like
but
dano is
incredible
and i think and this is my prediction i
think he's going to do it on the batman
yeah i think we'll
everyone's going to be great i think
we're gonna walk away again like paul
dano
uh i i i remember watching there will be
blood and and just
keep being confused about where the
vampires were
and like oh it's about oil
oh
i was just seriously going to kill that
dude right now you should [ __ ] stuff
your blood no
because he's he's like a plains vampire
he's hungry and
it's not that movie it's not it should
be
two the sequel sequel yeah there's blood
again yes there will be blood
yeah and now there will be bloods there
will be birds yeah nice this is why i'm
not a writer starring ice cube
nice
um
did you are you are you uh even though
you've been in a couple horror movies uh
sorry tv shows
uh are you a horror fan i hate it yeah
can't [ __ ] stand it i hate horror i
can't sit through it
i had to watch hill house to prepare for
blind manor i was so [ __ ] upset
and my meeting with mike flanagan my
first meeting with him went like this
nice to meet you how are you doing all
right thanks for coming up cool
i'm so [ __ ] upset with you over that
jump scare in the car
like what is [ __ ] wrong with you
and luckily he laughed but i was like
the the
you guys know what i'm talking about the
car seat where they're riding and then
and victorious screams
it i was so scared i didn't jump scare
i was frozen in fear i didn't scream i
didn't move i just was like inside i
went i lost it
um
yeah i hate it and then i just started
asking questions about you mcgregor
because he just did dr sleep
i didn't want to talk about blair i was
like so what's obi-wan like is he as he
as obi-wan as i think he is
did he show his dick
i think he looks at joe's dicolo
i similarly i'm a bit of a wuss when it
comes to horror yeah so i did not see
candyman
i'm gonna do it you're gonna do it i'm
gonna do it for that one yeah uh did
anybody else see the candymans
no not yet are you gonna
[Music]
it's it's i gotta make sure so
it's not
a complete reboot we're doing this again
it it you need to you should it is a
sequel right
would you would you say that you
shouldn't go into it not have seen seen
the original
okay yeah
i i saw the original one
30 years ago because old ass man
i remember digging it because tony todd
is the [ __ ] mac and so i will follow
that dude wherever
uh i am not gonna go see this movie
because i am that person who's like i
don't want it in my face i like it
but you can do it at home
horror is not as bad at home than it is
in the theater right
i i don't know because i haven't seen a
horror movie in a theater
in
i think the ring was the last horror
movie i saw on the theater
my my best friend beau
accidentally doesn't like horror
accidentally saw paranormal activity
before anyone knew about it
i don't know how he got to an early
screening and he went on a date and had
no idea what to expect and it rocked him
to his [ __ ] call
he was petrified for like weeks
um yeah i've not done it i yeah i'm not
doing it in a theater i just think
that's that's crazy i'm not doing that
will not happen um but it was number one
in the box office um this past weekend
and uh
and it's it's
we we keep finding ourselves in these
weird places where we would like to
celebrate the first of something
except it's the thing it's weird to have
to celebrate but candyman was the first
movie to open at number one of the box
office directed by a black woman oh wow
um
which is which is awesome for for nia de
acosta who's currently shooting the
marvels for marvel oh yeah of course
yeah yeah she's blowing up in a big way
it's kind of sad that like
we're still here like checking off
bursts of a thing that should no longer
be a first
no it should be the latest yeah but alas
but it won't be the last it won't be the
last and that's the main thing that's
that's the thing we can take solace in
um
i would ask you if you were a fan of the
werewolf by night comic books from
marvel but if you're a wussie maybe not
i've never heard of him
um werewolf by night was back in back in
like the 70s when marvel was on their
horror kick that's where like blade and
dracula and all that stuff comes from
werewolf by night was one of those books
and so now disney plus is making a live
action i believe werewolf by night movie
uh as a halloween special
uh that i think yeah 2022 i think
um
i uh i'm gonna watch it
because i'm hoping disney plus won't
actually scare my bowels clean
um but you never can tell i think you're
safe are you sure because there's
nothing going to go that hard until they
have some sort of clear like do they
have parental controls on disney plus
or is it all just mixed right now i mean
i think you can
oh they are gonna okay yeah not yet
because i think they're like you come to
dizzy plus you don't think you're gonna
get porn
you can watch animals [ __ ] though
yeah you can yeah meerkat nano i have
been on that tab
yeah more than two i like i watched
mandalorian because that's why i got
disney plus and i was like now what oh
sharks
meerkats [ __ ] apparently
um
quebecois tepee aztecs like i've been on
that that tabs that's been a wonderful
extra
subscription
look at you jump on that ah oh thank you
thank you my goodness
wine makes me gets me rose
i get scrappy
i throw hands yeah rosie
rose messes me up man
i can't hold my rose
the rose wave is gonna hit me in the
face
did you watch manifest
on the nbc's no uh currently it's on the
netflixes
and so
it got cancelled on nbc oh
right i know what you're talking about
yeah uh
four seasons i believe it went on nbc
and then got cancelled three absolutely
strong opinions about the news you're
about to deliver
so uh yeah three seasons it went on nbc
um apparently nobody watched it on nbc
uh so they canceled it that's how that
death that's how that checks out but
netflix [ __ ] were just binging
it like it was made of gold
and
the viewership on netflix is through the
roof oh wow okay to the point where when
nbc canceled it there was a whole like
safe manifest movement yeah you know the
fans got out they marched they they sent
in peanuts or plane tickets or whatever
the [ __ ] that movement was
and uh but netflix was like nah we're
not gonna do it
like we're thinking about it this
doesn't work out for us but then they
kept watching the show
to the point where they said all right
you know what [ __ ] it we will do a final
season yeah 20 episodes yeah they got
all the actors back they got the
director and the show runners back and
so
manifest is doing that which
a handful of shows have done before yeah
which is you know rescue a stalemate
from the jaws of defeat
and is that brooklyn nine-nine was
another one right there
i think lucifer lucifer was the big
netflix move yeah it was they they came
in it got cancelled on fox and then it
came to netflix and then they made 14
more seasons of losing supergirl did
that right cbs
they went from cbs the first season
sister company but they moved as well
right yeah um and so the question that i
have about it like i'm thrilled for all
of the the actors and performers and the
creators and the fans specifically they
wanted this
it's
how
netflix the netflix ecosystem is so
strong that they can make a hit out of a
show that was a flop on another network
yeah
and so what does that say about nbc what
does that say about broadcast as a
viable
sort of engine going forward for
delivering you content yeah if they
can't keep their own shows alive yeah
and then there was apparently a bit of a
bidding war between netflix and then the
peacock which is the nbc like that would
have been what felt like the logical
things like we got the show that's a hit
on the one service and if we make more
of it we can put on our service and
those people show up
but even peacock didn't think that they
could monetize it like that oh wow so
it's you know i'm
i'm gaming it out in my head which is
why they didn't offer what netflix
offered which was hey we have your first
three seasons we know people are
watching it we can close it out with a
bang
and we can bring more eyes to it than
anybody else can bring to it and it's
just the health and robustness of
netflix as a service compared to almost
everybody else yeah you know they can
make hits that nobody else can make yeah
and that is a that is an ecosystem that
is a shift in the business that i would
not have foreseen five years ago for
sure you know and like just the the
relative weakness of broadcast and the
the newness of all these streaming
services like
disney plus could maybe do it if they
wanted to you know um netflix clearly
can amazon didn't give a [ __ ] but they
could try like we'll spend 500 million
dollars on this yeah and then also we'll
bring back this show that you love
um which they did actually with um what
the [ __ ] is the um
expanse yeah like they they pull that
off of sci-fi when they cancel it says
well [ __ ] it you know jeff bezos loves
it so we'll make two more seasons yeah
that's how they do that [ __ ] that's
their math is like does the big guy like
it
um
was there ever any talk of that for i
zombie
[ __ ] no
no i i
to be honest like there is still people
that want a sixth season
this and i don't mean to be mean
spirited but why
so
for me
i like to be
sure and there's other stuff you can
watch us in like
for me
i felt that
we had told our story before we stopped
telling our story
it's a nice way to put that
and
and i and i have such deep love for that
show
um
but i think i don't think you want to
watch people limping you know and and
there's something to be said for for
particularly the british culture where
tv's concerned where
they stop making them at its height when
you want it most it's done and that's
and that's it and
i i love that idea
um and then you come to america and it's
a little different you get you'll get 14
seasons of a show people stopped wanting
after its second season
um
so yeah with izombie that i mean
there's a small demand for it
but
i i don't i think it's one of those
things where it's very easy to ask
and but it but i think rarely do people
follow through i think if we made a
sixth season no one would watch it
because they wouldn't because it's easy
to go i want this and you go here i'll
do it for you and then go i am [ __ ]
watching it
[Laughter]
do you know what i mean so it's like
it's like whenever i do these gundam
builds and everyone's like oh my god can
you make a youtube channel and stream
this and i'll be like okay but then only
four of you will watch
because it's easy to ask but you to find
the time to actually go follow through
and support something is completely
different so yeah it would be nice to
see ravi and liv and
some other characters get together and
and clive's my favorite person and
malcolm's my favorite human being in the
entire world i would
i'd pay so much money just to be in the
morgue and do one scene with those two
that was the the thing
but
it's not going to be as good and
no we would do another stuff and we're
happy but yeah like i i
i get very worried about
i got in a bit of trouble
with zack snyder fans
really
i don't understand they've always been
very reasonable to me but i made a mista
i made i made a bit of a mistake i
i had tweeted i did i did say something
it's a and i haven't spoken about this
because i you know i got in a bit of
trouble for it but
i worried i had wrote uh as a person of
color yeah i worried that
in zack's case with with the support
that the fandom had shown him
in showing in delivering his final
cut while that was a positive thing for
zach for the people involved for him for
the actors for the for for those who had
committed to making that story and then
that story wasn't then seen by people i
understood how that benefited that
i worried that by
not just that project but by setting a
precedent that enough screaming and
shouting gets you something
and teaching the internet that when it
used to be a bit more closed off
could be used for bad for instance if
they decided to cast a south asian
british actor as mr fantastic
is is fan pressure and bullying enough
to make disney to reverse that decision
when they take a risk if there's enough
of that
do they then walk it back
does that empower those to say well we
have more we have control
so if a season or a show is picked up by
another by a streaming service does that
again send the message of
if you if you harass us if we say to you
oh my god watch this new netflix show
and every tweet underneath it is hashtag
save manifest
and it's just bombarded that it works
and i worried about that in the case of
giving people from diverse backgrounds
telling stories about trans community
doing something that that that that that
would be deemed as risky that was
telling stories or giving
voice to those that hadn't before
if they decided to take that role
does that sort of say to them if you
make enough noise
we may walk it back we you do have more
power than you think and i that's why i
worried about that so that's
that's what i that's what i worried
about
and then
i booked a zack snyder show
and then they were like oh
talking [ __ ] about our mans and you had
to work with him and i was like he
doesn't care because i wasn't having to
go at you lot i was just worried i was
like hey
chill on the you know
because i worry i'm always i'm trying to
protect
creatives and you know anyway it's a
legitimate worry i have you know my
worry was a little bit different because
i came the same place as you were which
is
i love that zach got to make his movie i
like zac i met zach yeah he's a
wonderful human being he's a nice guy
um
and so i i don't particularly like many
of the movies he makes okay i like him
as a person so the fact that he gets to
be an artist and get his vision out
there all for it artists should get to
do that what i didn't like was that some
of the people who were asking for it the
most were also the same people who were
doxing journalists for
potentially having negative things to
say about it sure you know and and then
those people were living all kinds of
threats from the mildest to the most
extreme at people who are you know they
didn't have to be friends but they
happened to be friends
um many of them were women and many of
them were journalists of color yeah and
so that that level of finality and and
just antipathy
was worrisome to me and i i hated the
idea that those people got what they
wanted
and so i said that out loud and as i did
right now and got some [ __ ] for it as
you know potentially i deserved
but
i the way i always look at it is like
netflix did not renew manifest because
of the safe manifest movement correct
they did it because the algorithm told
them makes money yeah you know hbo max
needed a big splashy thing to launch a
streaming service with and they had this
and it's like well we could spend
another 20 million and finish it and
this can be a giant thing that we can we
can roll out of the barn
those things do collide they do because
the hashtag and the the noise does let
them know there is a built-in audience
for that so that in that respect it does
right it's indicative that that would be
something it emboldens a business
decision they were probably going to
make anyway sure with a little bit of of
of backup a little bit of defense a
little bit of cover in case of the well
with the fans don't don't warn about his
own hbo yeah
those are the same people it's all the
same people yeah yeah um
i don't know how we got here
oh because it was manifest it was
manifest it was manifest yeah um so like
listen i'm as i was happy for fans of
lucifer of which i count myself one of
the elusive fan uh was thrilled when it
came back for more sure for more
episodes i'm thrilled for the fans of
manifest and so the storytellers get to
finish their story i'm thrilled when
artists get to come to the ending of
their tale because it so rarely happens
in hollywood yeah so many things are cut
short so many things are are are put
through a system that that automatically
makes you compromise the thing you
wanted to do yeah and so that anybody
gets to to do what they wanted the way
they wanted to is a miracle and going
back to sorry to go you're going back to
izombie it was such a gift
to know that a bubble show that had such
poor audience numbers you know we
weren't doing great
um but we had such a wonderful
following
we were allowed we were told when we did
the 50s because we were never you know
we weren't like the flash where you knew
you was coming back every year we were
told every january to pack your [ __ ] and
go home and then we'd wait till may
and oh day before the upfronts mark
pelowicz and everyone will contact rob
and say
you're coming back so we always wrapped
for good when we finished our zombie and
we were always renewed
from the dead
to be told when we were finished season
four you can come back and do one more
season
and you're out you tell your story and
you wrap it up you put a bow on it
it's such a rare gift
like that's why i've like i'm so
appreciative of the cw i'm so pretty
because
hearing how often shows are just and
you're done
that's the that's the common trait to be
able to put to put a final chapter out
and kill it yeah yeah it's such a luxury
yeah um we have one last news story it's
a little bit of a downer but i never
like to look at these things as as
depressing
but ed asner the great ed asner died um
natural causes you know peacefully in
his sleep at 91 years old um he won more
emmys than any man has ever won before
seven i think five of them for lou grant
no way and then a couple of others as
time went on um
i don't think anybody would call him a
nerd per se uh or a geek at least to his
face but
he has had a hand in not just up which
is glorious and wonderful yeah
or elf
what's happening
you all can hear that though right like
it's not just me
hot
that's that's the scary [ __ ] when you're
like do i
anybody smell toast burning
oh excellent thank you
um
but yeah and so not just health not just
up but a ton of like voice work i was
just
it was grainy good this is what you're
doing cobra kai right yeah yeah he was
awesome he's johnny's johnny's stepdad
in that i think he's a dude who likes to
[ __ ] work
yeah pardon me and he's his range as
well his range is insane um let's say
he was jay jonah jameson in the 1990s
spider-man series he was hoggish greedly
and captain planet planeteers roland
daggett on batman the animated series
[Applause]
ed wunkler on boondocks
and uh and granny goodness in a bunch of
dc [ __ ] yeah um
and so like he was a [ __ ] worker and
he was a stamina he was a curmudgeon um
apparently both on screen and off but
you know [ __ ] sing the man's praises
like he worked for 70 years
and loved doing it yeah and apparently
was also a deeply committed
philanthropist and deeply invested in in
social causes um and put his money where
his mouth was in big bad ways so yeah i
mean raise a glass
[ __ ] boys and girls
[Applause]
these stars were stuffed right outside
sweet yeah let's go pour one out on ed
[Music]
one for you bro
um
and that is the end of the news my
friend
that's been some news it's been some
news rockets here
um
we have one more ad to read
we do and then we're going to do q and a
and you guys
the ads today
are [ __ ] saucy are they sexy
because this is a sexy theme the first
ad was all about getting your balls
smooth
the second ad
it's all about getting them hairy
you might think that seemed to be how
we're setting that up
but uh yeah the first one's about
getting your rocket smooth the second
was about getting your rocket to take
off oh
[Applause]
blue chew
boys and girls
blue [ __ ] chew it's summer
camping season
let's talk about pitching tents i don't
know why mark keeps looking at me like
this
this feels like a very targeted ad right
now
who have you been talking to
yeah i'm listening yeah it was just two
guys up here sure yeah
talking about dick [ __ ] can i borrow
that can i take that with me later the
script yeah yeah yeah no for sure thanks
you want to sign it i've been performing
my one-man show of [ __ ] ad reads
um
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate that's where blue chew
comes in this isn't as much fun as
manscape was i'm i'm sorry guys like i i
know i'm sorry no it's i think we're all
really paying attention yeah you think
it's different yeah i think most people
were grooming their balls
now they're like tell me more about
bluetooth right now yeah no all right
cool now now that it's this is a captive
audience
now that we've mowed the infield it's
time to play store so yeah exactly
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost
you can take them anytime day or night
wait so you chew on it yeah
so it's viagra but you just chew like
gum
well i think it's it's not no oh i think
it's a chew and swallow
oh okay gotcha good job i thought it was
like viagra chewing gum
i mean that's insuring and
that seems like some dangerous [ __ ]
science but you would spit it out when
you
don't want it to keep working
but if you don't
uh
yeah so the process is simple you sign
up at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you can receive
your prescription within days the best
part all done online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
about your dick no waiting in line at
the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package
yeah
you see what they did there
yeah is it called
blue chews
[Music]
so
if you could benefit from from some
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal deal just for all of you
try blue chew free when you use our
promo code fatman at checkout speak five
dollar shipping we have some samples now
for you to chew on yeah let's all get
our blue chew on
blue
so that's bluetooth.com promo code
fatman to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we thank bluechu
for sponsoring this podcast
that's great mark
i'm going into business reading about
dick pills um so we have a q a today we
have some things to give away for said q
a
yeah so stay right there
all right
how's everyone
doing thank you all for coming tonight
it's awesome you guys have been amazing
thanks
oh
i need a hero
i'm holding that that's one of the
greatest trailers i've ever seen
i lost because you know i was doing the
i saw it early did i tell you
oh so uh
firstly huge he-man fan
right secondly love the show but
because i was i happened to be hosting
the netflix geeked where you go where
the trailer was debuted right
so
so i got to see the trailer a few days
early before it was debuted and i lost
it and they also gave me screeners so i
saw the first five back in
july sounds right yeah
it's great and i squealed every time you
guys snuck in an 87 reference because i
spotted them all i'm
obsessed with the dolph 100 movie
that's where you should be oh yeah it's
fantastic um
i can quote that i can do skeletal
speech i know i'm deep deep into that
but um
no i'm i'm i'm in i need the second half
i need it uh i need it
things happen in the second half you got
any got any of them screeners again you
got anyone on the screen
uh
no okay
it's gonna end them scripts like that
that sounds a bit like a dude we used to
hang out in the back alley
hey man
suck your dick
bluetooth.com
uh so yes we have we have some he-man
toys and a mystery he-man box
and on top of that we also have thanks
to the the good folks at sounding point
la and the la philharmonic i have two
tickets to a series of performances at
the hollywood bowl
i have two tickets to the maestro at the
movies john williams on
can i win them what what how do i win
them uh you gotta answer the question i
guess um two tickets on the third of
november which is i think this friday
um
two tickets to black panther
you said november uh september my bad
uh
skywalker run you guys
uh two tickets to black panther at the
bowl on the 10th
and then two tickets to harry potter and
the half blood prince on the 17th harry
potter harry potter
i felt like that's the only time i could
do a british accent it's amazing it was
amazing yeah i've been working
uh it's either that or lots of roy kent
yeah which roy counters yeah
phoebe
[Applause]
[Music]
he's there ted
the the character we love the most the
soul yeah ah is that the french
how do you say it lasso lasso
um so yeah do we have some questions for
these uh fine folks to win these fine
prizes who's got questions
uh we'll go here first
you were you were on it
go yeah you've been here enough yeah man
come stand in the light dude you got to
get on camera or nobody will know
good luck
gentlemen
thank you for tonight i appreciate it
thank you hey man what's your name
jonathan jonathan how are you jonathan
i'm great i'm here with you guys so it's
amazing
we're having the best night
hey real quick before my question the
biggest jump i've ever jumped in any hot
horror anything was that car scene oh
yeah holy [ __ ] dude i
yeah yeah it's not funny no that's why i
was upset with him yeah yeah like it
feels like mike was like
putting up his middle finger at his
audience there's yeah it's a horrible
jumpstart sorry yeah
so
your question good sir my question for
you gentlemen is
i loved haunting a blind manor
if you could do a haunting show
but with the dc or marvel character
who would it be and what would the plot
be
a haunting show
dc or marvel uh dc or more religious dc
either one can i can i throw a curve
ball ooh
i would do the haunting of the crow
because that's such a tragic gothic
romance the chrome
i think that fits i think
um and it can be terrifying
eric draven uh seeking revenge that's
what i would i would use that comic book
property which isn't dc or
no
but we'll have it why not yeah it yeah
it's your answer you can do two another
curry manna
the hanukkah crowman um
i think i would do
lucian's library from the sandman
oh um just because it's the storehouse
of all stories right it's the every
every tale that's ever been told it
resides in that library um
and then what if they start to come
alive you know i thinking about it as a
tv show the the analogy that i always
use is that a movie when you're writing
a movie you're you're you're you're
building a road
and there's a beginning of that road and
there's an end of that road but you're
kind of on that straight line but when
you're doing the tv show you're building
a house and each one of those the house
has a hundred doors and each one of
those doors has an episode behind it and
so if the analogy is you're building a
tv show then i want to do a tv show in a
library where every episode is a book
that's on the shelves and if every story
ever told is on those shelves and half
of them are [ __ ] scary um
yeah that's what i do
thanks dc thanks give me money
um all right so so how should we do the
giveaway should we now wait till the end
uh let's let's do them as we go do them
as we go all right well since you were
first you get to choose
the box is a surprise that's how that
works it could be empty
it could be bluetooth
it could be
[Applause]
awesome
hello hey um i've been watching you guys
for at least you for five years with
kevin up here and kevin for over a
decade on this podcast it's uh surreal
to be here oh thank you dude what's your
name my name is akil
i'm sorry i'm kidding excellent good to
meet you i love your [ __ ] shirt dude
oh that is [ __ ] now i want that shirt
yeah it's a hot topic take it off
[Laughter]
so what's your question my friend yeah
so i have a really simple question since
we're talking about shows being
being brought back
and i was reaching recently watching
glory decks uh i have a question about
you as a writer and as an actor how
would you bring back these iconic shows
that people are so much nostalgia for
uh with the fine line that you have to
draw like you have to write those love
letters which lower deck scenes but so
much more fast paced that it doesn't
seem like star trek enough
um
i mean as as a writer especially dealing
with with intellectual property
especially dealing with something that
people love
it's remembering what they love about it
you know and the the thing that i think
people love about star trek
is is less the trappings of it you know
it's it's less because i love the
classic show as much as anybody does but
like those sets are a little cheesy the
special effects are a little cheesy
there's a charm to it but that's not why
i love that show you know which is why
when you look at something like next
generation or deep space nine or or
discovery is is watching people
synthesize the thing that they love
uh using a somewhat modern sensibility
unless you're doing a period piece in
which case whatever but even doctor who
which feels like it's nothing but period
pieces still contemporizes as time goes
on
but it's still about remembering the
thing people loved about at the first
place um
some people may quibble with the way we
attack masters the universe
but i think that anybody who engages
with it understands that it's coming
from a place of deep deep love for what
it was
while still trying to view those stories
and some of those dynamics and some of
those characters through a modern lens
because we are not the people we were in
1984. you know the world is not the
world it was in 1984. um the things we
are willing to accept from our dramas
and our comedies and our animation today
is different than it was in 1984.
and so there has to be some level of
contemporarization there has to be some
level of adaptation
and as long as you still have a star to
guide yourself by
that is the that is the only advice that
i can give which is find out what you
love about it and find ways to amplify
it and find the things that you didn't
love or didn't respond to and find ways
to minimize it
um and then maybe you can have something
that you're proud of as a storyteller
and that audience can engage with as
viewers and that everybody involved can
be proud of having made because it's
it's it's the spirit of the thing the
spirit of the law is sometimes better
than the letter of the law the letter of
the law will always [ __ ] you at the end
but the spirit of law is to protect
people and to to look out for the little
guy and the spirit of the show is the
thing that you're trying to to defend
and like candles around and worship at
the end of the day
that's awesome
mr actor actors are [ __ ] stupid we do
what the writers tell us to do
[Laughter]
we owe everything to writers we really
do uh they make us look smart they make
us look funny they do
they deep dive on the reference material
we're at their mercy so and i i honestly
i have such a low opinion of mine and my
crew
um
it's not on us the
yeah we're just there to um for the ride
really it's up to the writers
so i'm not going to talk on this one
you know but but i i
as as a writer for a very long time
before i worked in television it's not
that i didn't have a respect for the
things that actors did because i always
did because i knew it was something that
i couldn't do but i never knew how hard
it was
until i wrote a thing that somebody made
so much better by performing it sure you
know and it's it's a lesson i learned
working with andre holland on castle
rock
where like that dude is a [ __ ] titan
like
and we gave him so little to work with
because we
to be frank we didn't really know where
the first season was going while we were
shooting it you know we had an idea
generally but there were still so many
things up in the air so many things open
for debate that we hadn't answered some
of those questions until the very end
and so i remember being with andre on
set
and he was like so hey man um what what
happens to this character two episodes
from now i was like
to be frank
i'm not sure
but what i can tell you is here's the
character's journey like here's his ark
here's where he's going to land he's
going to land in a place of of resolve
and of understanding of who he is and
where he came from and why these things
are happening to him
and that gave him enough
[ __ ] talents to stick in said okay i
can i can push towards that i know where
that's gonna end i know what it looks
like to be lost and what it's gonna feel
like to be found
and
he he
found nuggets nuggets nooks and crannies
nuggets nougats [ __ ] i'm sticking with
the nougats but he found these little
like corners to live in and that
character found these little spaces to
inhabit and he brought so much to it so
much empathy to it that we couldn't put
on the page because only a great actor
can come to a thing and find out where
the life really lives and then make that
thing real well
at best we can elevate material because
the thing is
we have to think we think on such a
micro scale right like
writers are thinking on on
such a grand scale that it's multiple
characters there's a bigger picture at
work here and then we get in and we take
one
individual that you wrote about and
obsess about it for three months
so of course we're gonna we're gonna
investigate that and do things to that
and and find
nuance that
no one can be expected to do except that
individual you know
obviously for myself can i speak for
myself but i'm hyper focused on one
individual sometimes i lose sight of the
bigger picture because i'm so focused on
that so
we i think we can elevate but
the material has to be there
for it to be elevated so that's why like
when it comes to conversations about
story and writing and stuff i try and
kind of keep it mad real which is we do
[ __ ] all right um
we just we we can we get in on the day
and if you've got a joke we'll try it
six different times and we have the
tools to kind of like you know make that
work and give it the best chance it can
if you have a relationship you want to
work
two acts are going to find their way to
make sure that that's as you guys
intended like
but
that's it
that's what we do
but we didn't come up with it and you
know so the genius is always at that
point like yeah yeah yeah i don't know
it always feels a bit to me like it's a
it's a symphony
um and you can be the dude who wrote the
music and then there's a dude who
conducts the music and then there's the
orchestra and none of it works unless
everybody is doing the same thing and
pulling the boat in the same direction
and unless those musicians can play it's
just notes on a page and
reminding myself that it's this holistic
experience that it's it's you know you
got to go around the horn and make sure
everybody's giving their their all
that's what makes it sing um i hope that
kind of answered your question
more than that
maybe
i mean uh awesome dude well oh we forgot
john jonathan
you forgot to choose your movie sir
what yeah no it's a package we're not
doing this toying the thing a toy and a
thing to know anything in the toy
anything
so
that's generous mark
no not less too generous
harry potter it's all yours my friend
wow
now you get to choose a toy in a thing
here's what's left these two and this
and one of these
oh
yes battle cat
there you go yeah battle cat
all right and
all right then john williams is yours
which leaves black panther skellig and
mossman
ooh
i think she's got a question she wants
to ask i have a question i'm not gonna
take any prizes you better not but i
read on the internet somewhere that you
predicted many months ago the plot of
spider-man no way home
and i don't think that we've talked
about that tonight i i don't remember
what i said
nine months ago when we were talking
about [ __ ]
i guess it was far from home
and i get what does this is gonna sound
like the worst question does anybody
remember what i said
i know
i was like i've had a little bit of wine
what did i say
that got me into trouble
so well we saw the trailer what did you
guys think of the train
um
i you know i is that what we said did we
say that it was some [ __ ] like one
one new day
um [ __ ] for marvel comics where they
were going to oh come on man
i'm just i'm
i'm just a squirrel trying to get a
shave nut and you keep on i've slept in
these booths if you guys
need to sleep at all so and you're the
guy buying me drinks huh all right
i mean i dug the trailer um i i
it's still so early that i don't know
entirely what the movie is because it
feels like much of what we saw in that
trailer is the first act of the movie
which is my problem is everybody knows
that i'm spider-man how do i solve that
problem
magic which of course is the worst idea
ever
um
you know i think i think uh you know dad
bod doctor strange is a little
like rolling up on the sweats
let's do magic in my jammies
is a little like makes me wonder if
that's actually doctor strange or
yes or are we going to get the oft
rumored long threatened mephisto um
reveal which
who the [ __ ] knows i don't know how much
magic the marvel universe wants to get
into
um
but i will watch tom holland do [ __ ]
anything like that kid is so charming
that kid he's like 50 years old that kid
is so charming
um
and and the the sort of the mixture i
think john watts as a director now
understands these characters so well and
understands all of the actors strengths
so to sit there and watch zendaya just
sort of completely under sell these
lines and that's exactly what mj would
sound like and to watch tom just always
be kind of frenzied and panicked and and
always on the verge of a nervous
breakdown is exactly what spider-man
kind of should be
you know and
[ __ ] alfred molina like
strapping like i'm gonna take this shirt
off i'm 78 years old can you de-age my
chest a bit marvel because
nobody wanted this in 2006.
um
but
that little nod that and the little
[ __ ] green goblin bomb that rolls in
it's we are now we're getting all of it
yeah you know and it's a lot of it is
the things that we'd all been threatened
with and we'd all been um you know sort
of led to believe which is
this is the multiverse this is
everything spider-man all colliding all
the same time on top of each other and
that's
rad like i'm here for it you know and
and how much this
version of the multiverse and doctor
strange's spell
meshes with he who shall not remain and
the branching of all the timelines and
the king and the conqueror which also
melds with one division like all of that
[ __ ] is still kind of up for debate um
and then what doctor strange the
multiverse of madness with multiverse in
the [ __ ] title how that
amps any of this stuff up but
you know
i'm not not gonna watch it like
look where we are you guys we're all
gonna go otherwise you don't roll on a
tuesday night a nerd bar we're those
people um but i'm i'm i i remain
emboldened by the things that the marvel
universe does even when i don't love
everything they do
you know i was listening to
um this podcast with patton oswalt who
was talking about doing comedy about
things that he loves as far as the
things that he hates he's like when i
was a younger man i did a lot of comedy
about stuff that i hated
but the older i get the more i realized
that only
only by loving something so deeply can
you find the flaws in it and the flaws
are not flaws that render it invalid for
that love it's because you love it so
much you look at it so closely and you
see the things that may or may not be
awesome
but that's that's everything you love
that's marriage that's
parenting that's all of that stuff it's
star wars star wars we love it so much
that we we we look at it
we hate pieces of it because i [ __ ]
hate some star wars as much as i love
yeah because i love it so much i hate it
i'm not saying which films but you think
we know
um and so like i i love i love this [ __ ]
so much i love marvel i love dc i love
independent i love comic books i love
science fiction i love all of it except
for horror because me and her have a
whole thing yeah [ __ ] her [ __ ] her um
and so when i when i do stumble upon
something then i'm like you know what
it didn't work for me and here's why it
is out of a place of love um so i'm
looking for this to be as great as i can
i'm looking for everything to be it's
best possible version of itself
and when we see it we'll talk about it
and we'll say the things we loved and
say the things we didn't love
but that is that is the joy of being a
[ __ ] nerd is that we found ways to
love things and then we found ways to
look somewhat sideways at them at the
same time and and through that prison we
both get better at loving the things
then we get better telling the stories
and we get we become better nerds for
finding flaws and then looking past them
anyway meaning kevin will talk about the
things he loved and you'll talk about
the things you don't indeed
that is our relationship that is the
honeymooners we've built for the last 10
years
okay
we'll hand the mic back to the audience
thank you
okay all right yeah you got your light
hello
you have the best mask that is so
fabulous
oh sweet um but that's actually a great
uh lead-in to my question what's your
name hi i'm taz like the tasmanian devil
well met tez wellnet um so i am
an artist i am an i'm a fan of color i'm
a queer femme of color
i uh moonlight
i work in i.t by day and i moonlight at
night as a performance artist and i'm
also south asian so also thank you so
much i admire you so deeply rahul like
just your work i've been following for
years and it's just [ __ ] fantastic
and so as my question is as an artist
who is mired in
everything that like capitalism
and the patriarchy
and
and you know that all the pressure of
racism that we as artists of color
when we're creating our art
like when we're doing our art and we're
making it like i'm writing i'm writing a
musical right now and i'm writing an
album and i'm trying to just do the
right thing but like also get my
feelings out but do the right thing at
the same time
so how how does that for you as a writer
how does that impact
how you're writing and what you're
choosing to write and for you as an
actor how does that impact the projects
you're choosing to pursue because i'm
struggling with that because i want to
eat
but also i want to make art that i am
proud of that i can stand behind
that is uh
that is a that is a perfect last
question
um because i think it's the thing we'll
chew on the most um for me
i
my my journey to being a professional
writer like i was a journalist for a
very long time covering entertainment
um and then when i decided i wanted to
to make [ __ ] up for money um which i
then put on business cards i make [ __ ]
up for money um
i i began writing the things that i saw
the most you know and the things that i
saw the most as a person living in
america in the 20th century was stories
about
white protagonists white male
protagonists you know and i loved them
you know i grew up in the 80s like i
love [ __ ] predator and lethal weapon
and ghostbusters and and like that's the
kind of stuff that that when i started
writing
i wrote and they were fine you know they
they got me a job or two but they didn't
light the world on fire for me
um
it was only when i began
to incorporate the more i incorporated
of myself
into the work
a the better the work was and the more
people responded to the work and that
was this weird inverse logical
connection that i couldn't have made i
couldn't have planned i could have
gained that but it was and it was it was
the pushing myself to the
the the brink of giving up much like
your story of
i've been trying to do this for a long
time and i hadn't been getting any
purchase and and you know lots of doors
were closed even the doors that opened
ultimately went down blind alleys and
didn't lead anywhere
and
i i kept on getting to this point of i'm
gonna write one more thing
and if this thing doesn't work i'm gonna
just be a journalist like this is a
perfectly valid life to lead you know
like my dad is an accountant he can't
possibly love it
but he did it for 50 years and because
that's what people that generation did
you know kevin's dad was a mailman you
know i'm sure he didn't like love every
house he went to
he did the job because that's what
that's what men did they they took a job
they provided for the family they maybe
got two weeks of vacation a year and
they could afford a good christmas and
like that was it
and uh i was like you know i'm dreaming
this dream that might be selfish on my
part because being an artist is an
inherently kind of selfish thing
i wanna i wanna tell stories i wanna
dance i wanna i want i want to do things
that people notice
but the more i put myself into it
especially that very last script that i
wrote i was like listen this is it i'm
done i'll write this thing i'll put it
out in the world and see what happens
and that thing
which
happened to be about both me as a as a
parent me as a black person me as a as a
as an adult he's a man you know and this
desire in my heart to
to minimize the trauma that i saw on
screen all the time
you know i remember kevin asked me if i
had seen um underground railroad the
barry jenkins show which is beautiful
it's gorgeous but it was
too [ __ ] much for me like i just i
didn't want those images in my head
anymore i've i've seen
so much the tonnage
of sort of the the black trauma that a
black audience is forced to confront
any time of the year any year of the
decade but this year
last year
didn't want it
and so writing something that was about
people of color but did not have the
trauma attached to it you know and i
started going into meetings every
meeting i go into
because they start calling me because
i'm the black dude who writes genre [ __ ]
which is awesome like i love the fact
that that i am on a list that people
consult for that sort of thing
and i always say
i want to write things like into the
spider-verse because that is a that that
movie is so fundamentally brown it is so
much about that kid who's afro latino
effortlessly diverse effortlessly
diverse he flip-flops he code switches
like a [ __ ] like spanish to his
mom english she was dead like he's just
skateboarding and having the best life
ever it is about him being black but it
is not about blackness
and so being able to tell stories that
can
not be about pain and not be about
trauma but be about celebrating the
wonder of diversity about celebrating
the world that we live in and like i'm
still trying to to get like i have this
this idea like i want to tell
a [ __ ] coming-of-age story about
black kids about brown kids about asians
about everybody who never get those
stories
never get those stories i'm a [ __ ] 15
year old living in this place and it's
footloose but for brown kids where they
have nothing to worry about you know
maybe it's a fantasy but [ __ ]
breakfast club is a fantasy
i just want to be able to tell that for
people like me who grew up without ever
being able to see it
and so i think the work is for me anyway
is being able to do work that i'm proud
of and understanding that there's an
audience out there for it and drilling
down into what makes me happy the things
that i don't see
and then just putting it into the world
you know some of it's gonna hit some of
it won't you know and that's fine you
know like i i
it's a thing that i can't talk about
that much just yet but i can say
i went out on a pitch meeting i was
invited to pitch on this movie and i'm
like we're doing a version of this thing
i said great happily do a version of
this thing by the way this is the black
version of this thing
and like
did i get the job no
but
they were like i like that part of it
like it was a big [ __ ] swing and i
would much rather fail on a big swing
than just kind of limp to the finish
line on a
like
it's okay
you know so it's it's it's find the
thing that you want to say
and find a way to to say that thing
using the people and using the voices
that mean the most to you and then if
you can crack that nut and it's a tough
nut to crack because if everybody could
do it everybody would do it
but only you can tell that story
you know that's that's the thing that
emboldened me through that process was
i'm trying to tell a story that only i
can tell and i'm trying to tell a story
through a lens that only i have
and i have to believe because again
there are less professional writers
working than our baseball players that
i'm the only one who can bring that to
the table and somebody will want it
and we happen to be living in a time
where actually they're looking for it i
don't know how long it's gonna last i
mean we're in this weird [ __ ] window
period of like everybody claims to want
it and they're starting to pay for it
do it you know do it the best you can do
it and make sure that it's you and
you're proud of it you know don't
compromise on the parts of it that you
love the most
you know there's always room for
negotiation there's always room for
compromise there's always room for like
we can change some of this and tweak
some of this and whatever but you need
to [ __ ] build the walls around what
makes it special for you
and
[ __ ] if they don't like it they don't
like it that's fine
[Applause]
you know and i also think that part of
the work is finding the community who
also wants to row the boat in the same
direction is to find other artists and
other craftsmen and other performers and
and align those things together you know
how many south asian musical writers
no but i'm sure there are south asian
actors there's south asian performance
of south asian librettists one right
there
you know and not of course that you
should just [ __ ] like hammer this
dude but
they're they'll actually have a role for
him in my musical just like oh really
yeah you know i can't sing or dance
i um before i knew i was coming here
this is like months ago i wrote i'm not
making this up just to entice you it's
real
anyways go on um
so
the truth of the matter is
i don't think about any of it
i don't think you should put that kind
of expectation on yourself to worry
about representation
and what you're doing for your community
you lead by example so for me
i
just try and do the best job i do i kick
down the doors that are closed and i
hope they stay open for the community
behind me i don't actively shut them
behind me because it's very easy for
people of color to shut doors behind us
because the problem we face is if i act
the full on set they don't say royal
coley's a [ __ ] they say we give
these guys a chance and look what they
do look what they do with that
your movie bombs you don't bomb because
royal coley was bad in it it's because
no one wanted to see this indian guy in
it i can't take that kind of question so
for me what i do is i i just try and
i try and lead by example i try and
represent us every day but i don't think
about us every day i just think about
the job in hand the character that i'm
playing
and i think if you focus on being the
best writer you can be and tell them the
best musical you can tell you'll open
doors you will you will open doors by
the quality of your work
and the job opportunities that you open
that's that's what we need
so like and for me
the one thing i am conscious of and i
don't
i've never really said this out loud so
i don't know how this is going to go
down
i don't want green knight
that's dev's job good luck to dev
like that that's his role i don't want
to be up for green knight with dev
i want to take roles away from chris
pratt
i want to take roles away from chris
hemsworth i'm not saying i've got
anything against them but i don't want
six of us it's me it's riz it's it's dev
it's it's evan jogia there's like five
of us i don't want to be in competition
with these dudes
i want them to book the roles that
they're up for i want to take away from
the majority so i don't that's why so
when i approach work and my team are
very aware of this when you send me for
a role and it says south asian his name
is raj i go i don't [ __ ] want it and
then the next one comes in and it says
doesn't have a race
this is john 30s
handsome
i made that up it never says that
um
when it says that and i go oh they're
seeing everyone i want that [ __ ] role
so i want to take from the majority not
the minority so i don't i try not to
think about that's the only time i do
think about race
um
doing the and and
you spoke about you said you said
something about uh
doing the right thing
rights of perspective
it is i'm about to sound sith here but
we all have a different definition of
what's right and wrong because the truth
of the matter is
i should have said no to ravi
chakrabarti the doctor how many more
[ __ ] south asian doctors or asian
doctors do you need on tv
right
am i right so i got a stereotype sent to
me i got a doctor and guess what
he doesn't get the girls
and he's a geek
and he's smart
and the the lead don't fancy him guess
who guess who she fancies the dude with
the six-pack the white boy
major lily white
so
am i not in the name it's right there
right they didn't even [ __ ] hide that
[ __ ] so
i'm taking the role of dr ravi
chakrabarti
do we need it
is it right to take it should i do that
does that harm how we're perceived am i
just contributing to to the same
stereotype
or
do i [ __ ] ignore that
take it say i'll do everything they want
and then not
and then flip that stereotype and make
ravi
the comedic like add edge to him take
away some of those series from within do
i start saying to them ain't [ __ ]
doing that storyline i'm not doing that
let's let's let's try and meet in the
middle oh
ravi and payton is now a thing oh okay
so peyton
see what i'm saying so like i took
something that i shouldn't have
that was kind of on paper and you yeah
and you flip it so i don't know what
right is it's you know what i'm saying
like i don't know what right is but
now when you point at ravi that's not a
stereotype i know it's not a stereotype
because i made damn sure that's not a
stereotype
so
and i did it because also and here's the
here's the real [ __ ] rub
i did it because
i myself struggle with being a
self-loathing south asian
and that's something that that's that's
like uh that's a weird thing to clap but
but that's but that's something that
people of color
that's something that that that children
of immigrants particularly suffer with
is that the thing that we try to hide at
school my name's not raul it's rahul the
things that when we when we you know
when we're born in a country where we're
not necessarily
where we're the minority we hide it we
don't we we're ashamed of it we cover it
up at school we try to wipe up like nah
ain't like i ain't like a [ __ ] indian
dude all that stuff
weirdly benefited me because i was so
adverse to playing stereotypes that i
spot them a mile of because i was like
that in life
i don't know what's right or wrong
so it's hard to kind of have this
barometer you know what i'm saying so
i i kind of keep it as simple as i can
don't worry about the rest of us
like
you just do if you do the best job you
can possibly do if you could be the best
writer you can if i can be the best
actor i possibly can
and i don't
act up on set
and i don't slap someone or
whatever as long as i do because i know
that that's the unfair thing with being
a person like i said we have all
punished for one's actions because
that's the weird [ __ ] up thing when
you know we were all brought in for some
reason yeah you're all like that so as
long as you just be the best
like keep it simple the best writer or
the best actor or the best musician you
can possibly be will walk through that
door with you don't worry about because
that's too much expectation
and and and like i said right and
wrong's too binary because
if it was i shouldn't have taken ravi i
shouldn't have taken that role because
it's a stereotype oh crap but
again i did i took it and i changed it
for weird reasons but they still
benefited us in the long run so
i don't know if that makes any sense
whatsoever but i hope that means
something to you
i really i really needed to hear that
thank you both so much i really
appreciate no it's it's it's our
pleasure and it's there are so many
different ways to find your way to the
solution to that problem
you know and it's not a problem it's an
opportunity and that you know we always
call them problem tunities in the room
like well this sounds bad it's like well
but yeah but when we solve it it's going
to be awesome
you know and like do do what
strikes a chord in your heart and like
like you know raul said
just [ __ ] be the best version of you
and then find your way to tell your
story you know and then everything else
you know if it's done well and if the
gods smile on you um we'll lead to the
next thing um but yeah too much pressure
you know doesn't always make a diamond
it also crushes [ __ ] rocks so and we
don't need any more pressure so don't
put that extra [ __ ] on yourself like you
know i know we represent we can't help
it but you know
if i thought about every [ __ ] indian
every audition and every i'd crumble you
know it's it's too much it's way too
much just think about the art like i
said you do a [ __ ] great job you're
opening indoors you're doing it so don't
worry about it
sorry max no it's all good
[Applause]
you get toys and you get to go see black
panther
on the 10th
at the hollywood bowl with a live
orchestra because
[ __ ] life is good i love you sorry by
the way
you can have both of them if you want or
we can do one more question and give
that last one away
should i give it to someone
no we'll do one more question
yeah we'll do one more question it's
just a toy question it's just a toy
question you don't get to go see
anything cool
really quick i know everybody has to get
home
basically what's your name kyle kyle
behind the camera we follow each other
um basically what's a new indie project
that deserves more shine like we've
talked a lot about franchises we all
love genre we all love all these
different things but what's something
new that you guys have discovered and
feels like uh we should go check it out
when we go home
oh new
see news a bit rough because
just indie just india is good uh i
desperately want to see green knight i
haven't seen it yet
have you seen green knight no no you're
a bad south asian i know right
cause i'm like
i don't want to get fomo when i watch it
no i i um i was supposed to i think we
had tickets right and um we had to
reschedule because of work commitments
but yeah it was on my list because it
looks it looks phenomenal i gotta
support my boy you know what i mean he's
crushing it um but i will yeah there's a
movie that that i fell in love with that
that i saw because you know somebody
recommended that it was cool
um it was the first movie by a filmmaker
named jd dillard um called slight
it was a sundance movie
it was like really small they made me
spend like three or four million dollars
on it but it was about this sleight of
hand street magician
who
bio hacks his
his arm he implants some kind of
electromagnet or whatever so he could do
like legit [ __ ] magic um
and then all of the troubles that i mean
it's about a black kid in the hood who
figures out how to do magic and then
ends up in dutch with like gangsters and
drug dealers and all that [ __ ] but it's
this incredibly sweet story ultimately
about a guy just trying to get out you
know who will do whatever he needs to do
to get out and the magic of it is you
know how he retains his sense of self
while still undergoing and pushing
through what ultimately become like kind
of insane circumstances
but it's it's a thriller it's a
coming-of-age story it's a bit of a
romance and it's a [ __ ]
he's a superhero what's it called slight
slight s-l-e-i-g-h-t slice um and then
jd dillard would then go off to like
make
a bunch he's doing a star wars [ __ ]
movie because that dude is that [ __ ]
dude
um but yeah exhausted
[ __ ] best
um but yeah that's that's what comes to
mind of like relatively recent indies
that i just kind of stumbled on if i
love also the terminator if you've never
seen it
the first one
is amazing
are you familiar with this movie if
we're playing that game star wars is an
indie movie uh it very much is you
should see star wars um
because it's an independent film um yeah
well not the first one there's the first
one fox paid for it the other ones it's
the other ones yeah yeah yeah empire
strikes back is one of the best indie
films you'll ever see
and the phantom menace and attack of the
clones
technically
i made an indie um
it's really weird
the indie film that i shot this year
that i'm self-promoting because
i need to um
i post too much about gundams and model
kits so
i never put my own projects i made an
indie this year was my first first film
where i'm one of the leads
um
and i'm not allowed to talk about it
weird the title the pictures they are
more secretive than midnight mass it's
the weirdest [ __ ] like it made no sense
to me
they've got their reasons but i've got
an indie film it's it's really
really good it's got some really good
people in it um and if you follow me on
social media apparently i'm allowed to
tweet about it soon oh okay so you hear
about it i'll say this it's directed by
marley elfman
who's danny hoffman's daughter it's her
directorial debut
yeah and um she was she was a producer
who contacted me from mike
and um so yeah we we shot that this year
and it's
very oh i'm already
i'm like this close to starting bar
fights
i think i might have to not only because
i've got a nice little terrarium
building in here i got a couple flies
swimming
yeah i guess so it's all you baby
um but yeah that's an indie project
um
we're gonna know the name of that when
you tweet it right oh [ __ ] it's called
next exit
i shouldn't have done that in it uh
hey man ah
it's a skywalker rose
it is good we saw it [ __ ] it it's next
exit
it's that's what it's called i don't
know why they're being secretive jesus
well because what's at the next exit to
narnia
i play ezra bridger in it
tweet about it tweet it
that's right
whatever happens now is your fault
fine i'll take it excellent
thank you sarah for your question would
you would you like to have a moss man
[Applause]
uh
you guys
i think that's a show
wow i think we did it
um
i i
like
i went on youtube right yeah and typed
in black man beyond yeah yeah
and i was like i want to know what i'm
getting myself into and you showed up
anyway and i did and i saw the the run
time on it and i went two [ __ ] hours
and it's flown by and i hope it did for
everyone else too but yeah that's it's
been amazing thank you for having me
appreciate it have you had a good time
tonight
[Applause]
so much of that is because of the man to
my right mr rahul coley who showed up
and [ __ ] knocked it out of the park
um thank you to the good folks at uh
scotland villainy namely jc for
continuing to host
this insanity
uh thank you to the folks at sounding
point la and the la philharmonic for
giving us the tickets that we could give
away to you folks
and uh and that's a [ __ ] show
um
my name is mark bernardin
he's rahul coley
uh stay tuned kevin will be back shortly
i don't know when maybe not [ __ ] it
we'll keep doing this until he shows up
um but until then um
stay tuned same fat channel
same fat time
uh
smodcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
good night everybody
thank you
[Music]
you